día número 33 de la guerra en ucrania
este día ha iniciado con intensos
combates en el sur en el este del país
cerca de la martirizada hardcover
protestas pro craneanas en la ocupada
persona sirenas que se han vuelto a
disparar en todo el país y también una
situación incierta en kiev la capital
ucraniana donde las tropas rusas no
están avanzando pero todavía siguen
produciéndose escaramuzas en este
contexto los médicos ucranianos han
alertado también de un aumento en el
número de bebés que están haciendo de
forma prematura como consecuencia de la
guerra y también la economía está siendo
duramente afectada precisamente según el
ministerio de economía ucraniana el país
ya ha perdido 560 mil millones de euros
como consecuencia directa de este
conflicto en lo que va de la guerra